there are 500 million people from 27
countries
living in the european union we have the
right to live
work travel and shop anywhere in europe
we make over a billion cross-border
trips every year
and 12 million of us live in another eu
country
but sometimes we face barriers to our
rights and our freedom to move across
europe
the european union is working to make
sure everyone benefits from the same
rights
in everyday situations
one in six europeans have a disability
of some sort
they should have equal access to goods
services and technology
whether it's getting a job taking a bus
or surfing the internet
with a population of 10 to 12 million
the roma are the biggest ethnic minority
in europe as eu citizens they have the
same rights as everyone else
without having to face discrimination or
exclusion
as a european citizen your rights are
protected
at home abroad and online